on dit du entre les vénitiens sont
malins par exemple c'est pareil c'est
des cons parce qu'ils ont ils ont fait
la plus belle ville du monde ils ont un
million et demi de touristes par an ils
sont plus chez eux et s'appuient savait
pas vivre ces gens là dans le 14e on est
chez nous personne nous emmerde
[Musique]
la droite c'est une des artères les plus
importantes du quartier la rue de la
gaîté à boyet bobino qui était un centre
d'attraction et puis à côté de bobino il
ya un petit musée qui s'appelle le
moulin delahaye étaient en toi l'âge de
12 ans et de 18 ans j'ai traîné mais
latin peu tous les soirs le bel en
criant vous voyez là s'appelle le lion
de belfort
il est très laid comme vous pouvez voir
et ça ça fait partie de notre malice
c'est pour éloigner le touriste je les
ai connus verdâtre couleur bronze
maintenant on l'a pas en marron c'est
encore plus sachez qu'avant on a
plusieurs petits trésors comme ça alors
tout ça c'est la frontière déjà ça parce
qu'après c'est le cinquième
oui on change de quartier genova
longtemps à franchir cette frontière là
d'ailleurs j'ai mis 25 ans je retourne
dans quatre ans on est méfiant dans
l'iliade l'on n'aime pas tellement passé
les fonder la rive droite j'en parle pas
assez des daf jungle est celle ci je
suis tombé directement de la maternité
port royal en 27 départs qu'on
souhaitait
à 20 heures d'hier
mais un bête bien laine soie comme
toutes les autres du quartier elle l'a
fait en chaussée le quartier des bonnes
soeurs mais à l'époque où j'étais gosse
la nuit ici les y aller
il ya aucune bonne femme seule qui
voulait remonter cette année là on se
faisait plus ou moins violés ou
assassinés c'était vraiment le désert il
ya toujours pas de réverbères d'ailleurs
la rue du cimetière lé lé calme et on y
faisait les promenades sentimentale
réussi parce qu'ils financent le soir
c'est pas déjà lé s'ouvre peut pas dire
que ça circule bourgou mais la nuit
c'est plus que le cal a le parc
montsouris c'est un seul endroit
paisible du quartier la nuit une fois
les grilles du parc fermé à laon
on enjambait les grilles appuyons passer
pour pas la nuit bien sûr mes enfants en
travers les 1h du matin frais dans la
halle parc était à nous c'était nadia à
partir de là temps en temps il y avait
des cours avec les gardiens quand même
c'est arrivé mais reste fragile en
cavale l'état
mais là on a branché dollar une des
pièces artistiques les plus étonnantes
du 14e arrondissement
l'observatoire du parc montsouris alors
ça c'est à la fois notre place
saint-marc nos chutes du niagara nos
pyramide c'est la pièce artistique
maîtresse du 14e arrondissement
or voilà nous voilà devant saint pierre
de montrouge
les touristes se sont rués sur le sacré
coeur et là encore on a un coup de pot
inimaginable car personne ne vient
visiter d'intriguer les voisines de
l'école
la rue du moulin vert oui j'ai passé de
certificat d'études avec mention bien et
ça j'y tiens parce que dans mes
relations je connais que deux gars que
j'ai eu la mention bien aux certif c'est
maurice biraud et francis blanche pierre
lyall rase pas hiver cette émission
comme ça qui a l'air de rien et quand
j'étais enfin j'étais en gt plus bas
j'étais adolescent c'est là j'ai
rencontré césar gilles cometti enfin des
gens qu'on fait leurs cheveux et puis
maintenant c'est new york elle en ligne
là on n'est plus chez nous on sent trop
fut c'est une autre vie c'est un autre
monde
c'est pas mal d'ailleurs mais moi j'ai
pas encore eu le temps de me wehr elbe
il dit n'y a pas fait plus rien
[Musique]